- The story of Hanukkah
is like a miracle because
I'm just like barfing up latkes.
- Everybody loves potatoes!
- Potatoes are good.
- And everybody loves latkes.
- My mouth is already like salivating.
- I know I'm so hungry.
- I just drooled on myself, sorry!
- You know what I'm
actually doing after this?
- What are you doing after this?
- I'm going to a latke party.
- There's latke parties?
- Yeah, it's Hanukkah right now.
- So like in my experience,
you just do this.
- You just, oh, okay.
I don't even need these.
- This is delicious.
- You can't wrong.
It's just oily.
It's like basically
tater tots smushed down.
- Apple sauce, eh?
It's just so unorthodox.
- Cause Latin folk, you come to my house,
and if I give you,
and I'm like just put a
little sour cream over it.
- I like the sour cream a lot.
- What even is sour cream?
- Jewish food, American condiments.
American Jews, rejoice.
- Okay, what's next, jam?
- No.
- Nope.
No way.
- There's peanut butter.
- You gave him peanut butter?
Why?
- Do you remember the double
down sandwich from KFC?
- No.
- It was like chicken,
something in between, chicken.
But I'm thinking latke, PBJ, latke.
- Do you want to try it, here.
- Yeah.
New tradition.
- See, Latin folk, Jewish people.
We have the same hair texture.
A lot of us are equally as hairy.
I'm super hairy.
L'chaim!
- Still beats the shit
out of the eucharist.
- What's that?
- You know, that little piece of Christ
that you eat every Sunday?
- I mean like, no, I don't.
I'm Jewish!
- What a good Jewish boy.
- It must have been a great moment
of cultural exchange you guys.
- I'm really glad we did this.
And I'm also glad that I
have a Jewish friend now.
- One Jewish friend.